bonjour je m'appelle sigia Aurélie j'ai
22 ans et j'habite au port j'ai mon
permis de voiture et donc je suis
véhiculée je suis en recherche d'emploi
dans le secr dans le domaine du
secrétariat ou de la comptabilité j'ai
un niveau bac pro secrétariat
comptabilité et un titre professionnel
dans le
commerce en tant qu'employé commercial
en magasin j'ai fait plusieurs stages
dans le secrétariat et la comptabilité
et aussi dans le commerce dans dans le
secrétariat j'ai fait un stage pour une
grande une grande entreprise
d'importation exportation de vin dans le
commerce j'ai travaillé dans un grand
centre commercial en tant qu'employé de
rayon je suis quelqu'un de très
dynamique de très
motivé j'ai beaucoup d'ambition et je
veux continuer dans le secrétariat ou
dans le commerce parce que c'est un ce
sont deux métiers qui qui me
caractérisent vraiment beaucoup